Factor 4y squared
plus 4y minus 15.
So we don't have a leading
coefficient of 1 here.
And it also doesn't look
like we can factor out a 4,
since 15 is not divisible by 4.
So what we're going to try to
do, is factor this by grouping.
In the factor by
grouping, we want
to look for two numbers
whose product is
equal to the product
of 4 and negative 15.
We explained it in other
videos why this will work.
But let's just look
for those two numbers.
So the product is going to be
equal to 4 times negative 15,
which is negative 60.
And their sum needs to be equal
to this 4 right over here.
So a plus b has got
to be equal to 4.
And if we can figure out an
a and b that satisfy this,
so we can break up this
4y into an ay plus a by.
And then we can
factor by grouping.
Now the first clue here is
that the product of the numbers
is negative.
So that means that a and b
must have different signs.
And since a plus
b is equal to 4,
we know that the--
and I want you
to think about
this a little bit.
We know that the difference
of their absolute values
must be equal to 4.
Let me just make that concrete,
that little statement I just
told you.
If I were to say, well,
let's just say that I have,
let's ignore this for a second.
Let me just take
two simple numbers.
If I have negative 2 times 3.
Those two, the product is going
to be equal to negative 6,
and then their sum, negative
2 plus 3 is equal to one.
Notice, their
product is negative,
so they had to have
different signs.
And their sum is 1 and
they have different signs.
And one is also the difference
of their absolute values.
The difference between
the absolute value of 3
and the absolute
value of 2 is one.
That's what I'm talking about.
So this gives us a
clue of essentially
how far apart are the
absolute values of the number.
So let's think about all
of the factors of 60.
And then remind
ourselves that we're
looking for numbers
that are 4 apart,
numbers whose absolute
values are 4 apart.
One has to be positive,
and one has to be negative.
So the factors of 60,
you could do 1 and 60,
you could do 2 and 30.
I'm going to run out of
space doing it this way,
let me write it as a column.
So you have 1 and 60, you have
2 and 30, you have 3 and 20,
you have 4 and 15, you have
5 and 12, you have 6 and 10.
This looks pretty tantalizing
since these are 4 apart.
And then that looks
like we are about done.
7 doesn't go into it, 8 doesn't
go into it, 9 doesn't go do it.
We're done.
Now already, we already
talked about the difference
of the numbers, the absolute
value of the difference
has to be 4, so 6 and 10
looks pretty tempting.
But let's just go through all
of these numbers over here.
So the possible sums here,
if we make 1 positive and 60
negative, then it's going
to be a negative 59.
Remember, I'm making sure
that we have different signs.
If this is positive, this
could be positive or negative.
And this is negative
or positive.
I wrote it upside
down here, to show
that their signs are different.
So it's either going to be
negative 59 if this is positive
and this is negative, or it's
going to be positive 69 if this
is positive and
this is negative.
So it's negative or
positive 59, I should say.
This right over here is going
to be negative or positive 28.
You see that the absolute
value of, the difference
of the absolute values of
these numbers keeps showing up.
Now we know that we want
to go to 4, so let's
just cut to the chase
and go to 6 and 10.
If we take positive--
and we want
them to add up to a positive 4.
So the larger number
should be positive.
So if we take positive
10 and negative 6,
their sum is definitely
going to be equal to 4,
and positive 10 times
negative 6 is negative 60.
So let's break it up like that.
So what we could do is
break up the 4 as a sum,
break up the 4y as a sum
of a negative 6y and a 10y.
So let's do that.
So 4y, I'm going to write
as negative 6y plus 10y.
If you add these two
together, clearly you get 4y,
and then we have the
rest of the problem here.
We have the 4y squared minus 15.
Now we're ready to
factor by grouping.
Let's group these
first two terms,
and we can because they
have common factors here.
They're both
divisible by 2 and y.
And then we're going to group
these two guys, both of them
are divisible by 5.
So if we factor this
first one over here,
let's factor out a 2y over here.
4y squared divided by
2y just gives us a 2y.
And then negative 6y divided
by 2y is negative 3, right?
y divided by y is 1, negative
6 divided by 2 is negative 3.
Then let's factor
this guy over here.
We can factor out a 5, so this
is plus 5 times 2y minus 3.
And now lucky for us, we
can factor out a 2y minus 3.
So we have 2y minus
3, times 2y, plus 5.
And we are done.